qué características son compartidas por
fx eje x selecciona todas las que
apliquen nos dan f x que es el polinomio
x al cubo menos x y nos dan glx definida
esencialmente por esta gráfica de aquí y
nos piden decir qué características
comparten así que nos dan estas opciones
veamos
ambas son impares bueno para empezar que
x podemos notar luego luego que no es
impar porque todas las funciones impares
tienen que pasar por el origen y que x
no pasa por el origen pero vamos a
recordar brevemente qué significa que
una función se impar
recordemos que el x es impar sí sólos y
para todas x gx es igual a menos g de
menos x así que tomemos los dos valores
aquí que les parece 3
entonces en 3 la función g toma el valor
es igual a 4 en firme lo noto de 3 es
igual a 4
si la función fuera impar entonces g de
menos 3 debería ser menos 4 simplemente
pasando al menos de este lado de la
expresión pero cuántos g de menos 3 g de
menos 3 aquí lo tengo es cero
y de menos 3 fue 04 no es lo mismo que
el negativo de 0 así que esta función no
es impar por lo tanto esta no puede ser
porque no es impar tienen un máximo
relativo en el mismo valor de x pues
pensemos que significa que tengan un
máximo relativo significa que hay un
valor que es mayor a todos los valores
que están cercanos a la función por
ejemplo si la gráfica fuera algo así
quizás entonces aquí tendríamos un
máximo relativo porque este número la
función toma un valor más grande que
cualquier valor de los que tomás cerca
de este punto así que en este caso de x
es una línea recta y no tiene un máximo
relativo por lo tanto esta opción
tampoco puede ser
veamos tienen el mismo comportamiento en
los extremos esto es interesante que
significa que tengan el mismo
comportamiento en los extremos pues
significa que actúan del mismo modo
cuando x se hace o extremadamente grande
o extremadamente pequeño vamos a ver
primero empecemos con fx
x se hace muy grande entonces x al cubo
es mucho más grande que x por lo tanto
este es el término que domina y entonces
f x tiende a infinito porque este número
se va hacer cada vez más y más y más
grande y se hace más grande muchísimo
más rápido que la x solita cuando
cuando x tiende a infinito y qué pasa
cuando aquí se hace muy pequeña veamos
f x tiende a donde cuando
cuando x tiende ahora a menos infinito
eso es que x se haga muy muy pequeña
pues si aquí se hace muy muy muy pequeña
entonces x al cubo se hace muy muy muy
muy muy pequeña se hace pequeña como el
cubo de veces que x entonces de nuevo
este término es el que domina y como x
al cubo para un número negativo siempre
va a ser un número negativo cuando x se
va a menos infinito f x se debe ir a
menos infinito también muy bien qué pasa
ahora con g de x pues gx como decíamos
está definido por la recta y esta recta
cuando aquí se hace cada vez más grande
simplemente sigue subiendo y subiendo y
subiendo por lo tanto gx también se hace
muy grande y cuando x se hace muy muy
pequeño la recta sigue bajando y bajando
y bajando y bajando por lo tanto x se
hace también muy pequeña de modo que si
tienen el mismo comportamiento en los
extremos finalmente nos dicen comparten
una intersección con el eje x pues aquí
tenemos las intersecciones de gx sólo lo
corta una vez corta una vez al eje x
y es precisamente en -3 para encontrar
las intersecciones con el eje x de x al
cubo menos equis simplemente voy a
factorizar esto podría factorizar la
equis y escribir esto como x por x al
cuadrado menos 1 ahora esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados por lo tanto
puede escribirlo como x por x menos 1
por x más 1
ahora bien la intersección con el eje x
se da cuando el valor de fx es cero por
lo tanto esta expresión de aquí se tiene
que anular tiene que valer cero y eso
pasa cuando x es igual a cero porque en
este caso este factor se anula cuando x
es igual a 1 porque en este caso este
factor de acá se anula este de aquí o
cuando x es igual a menos 1 en cuyo caso
se anula este factor así que estas son
las tres intersecciones que tiene f x
con el eje x y claramente ninguna de
esas es la misma que la intersección de
gx con el eje x por lo tanto ésta
tampoco es cierta la única
característica que comparten es que
tienen el mismo comportamiento en los
extremos